I think a condiments job is to make
everything that you're eating tastes
better if it doesn't elevate then why
add it banana sauce why is it red that
makes no sense
smells like ketchup it smells nothing
like bananas this label is lying to me
is this sauce that's made from bananas
or is it a sauce for banana to shake
well yeah Wow on the way to barbecue
sauce but then took a left at banana
Grove this would be great on chicken
fingers I tell you if you're drunk you
wouldn't know there wasn't ketchup maybe
what sort of say it's good how do we
sass bread Oh hop what are you oh it
smells like it might be spicy this is
really good it's very tangy this would
be really good on pasta or Road Shibata
I hate it at first bite and now it's
dancing on my palate and all I want is
more some ball Taurasi condiments ah it
smells like this spiciest chili at the
chili cook-off there's shrimp in here
let's see what this is like
before the spice kicked in I won't say
it a great day
I'm pretty impressed with how much in my
mouth is it it's already affected I
think you could put on rice maybe a nice
stir fry
whenever you stuff gets to a certain
like heat level it doesn't have flavor
anymore they're two ingredients of
salted shrimp one is shrimp
the other is salt so they're little
shrimpy eyes oh god it smells exactly
like you think it smell confirmation
that the little black spots are their
eyes no oh my god there's so much chalk
on it 40% of your daily sodium is in
here 33 times it would be good on like
things that need salt how does this
qualify as a condiment so this is
fermented bean curd bean curd is great
tofu it's soy this is disgusting at
least this didn't crawl around at some
point
Oh what's up Oh nope
smells very sweet Oh God
that is literally the worst thing I've
ever tasted in my life coating my whole
mouth and the salty slime I'm gonna have
to date get married have children and
that taste is gonna be my mouth I might
be allergic to that what do you do with
this this would go good on a Viking
funeral boat that you put out into the
ocean and then shoot a flaming arrow
toward there are probably people that
love this everybody's got a different
tongue right dude snack well I'm ready
I'm at me pretty good